ви знаєте коли тільки почалося
повномасштабне вторгнення багато хто в
світі порівнював президента Зеленського
з черчелем для України Це було добре
тому що ну це дуже таке яскраве
порівняння інша історія наскільки воно
відповідає дійсності але що добре для
країни то добре але що насправді зробив
черчель коли став прем'єр-міністром в
просто вирішальний для долі
Великобританії час в травні 40го року
перше Що він зробив Він запросив лідера
опозиції стати своїм заступником етleй
він об на весь парламент в єдину
коаліцію всіх в одну команду боротьби за
державу всім дав роботу і завдання що
зробив наш черчель ні маргіналізувати
опозицію ніякого об'єднання давайте
терміново це виправимо створимо уряд
національної єдності